[Applaus]
[Musik]
als ich das deutsche kaiserreich gegen
ende des ersten weltkriegs in einem
samurai münden zweifrontenkrieg verrannt
hatte kam den deutschen ein geist ist
dessen drastische folgen zu den weiteren
verlauf der weltgeschichte sich so wohl
nie und nimmer vorhergesagt hätten
trotzdem was haben sich die kaiserlichen
beamten nur gedacht sie müssen schon
ziemlich verzweifelt gewesen sein und
sich zum zwecke der der stabilisierung
ihres feindes im osten mit jemandem zu
verbünden der für die damalige deutsche
monarchie doch noch viel gefährlicher
war der kommunist und boxer wladimir
iljitsch uljanow besser bekannt als
linie
immerhin die bolschewiki hatten die
russischen arbeiter schon zu beginn des
krieges dazu aufgerufen nicht gegen die
deutschen sondern gegen das verhasste
zaren region zu kämpfen dieses wurde
1917 jedoch nicht frische wiki sondern
von den bürgerlichen aufständischen zu
fall gebracht das problem für die
deutschen dabei die neue bürgerliche
regierung in sankt petersburg wollte
nicht so einfach vor ihren einknicken
also holten sie ihren joker aus dem
ärmel linien und seine führungstruppe
saßen damals im schweizer exil store und
konnten den geschehnissen in ihrer
heimat nur aus der ferne zu sehen die
deutschen setzen sie also in einem zug
der sie über frankfurt stockholm und
finnland nach sankt petersburg bringen
würde und statteten sie außerdem mit
ausreichend kapital aus um die
kommunistische partei und presse in
russland aufzubauen und so entstand
orchestriert durch das auswärtige amt in
berlin eine der wichtigsten supermächte
der weltgeschichte die sowjetunion
[Musik]
überrascht man warte ab was jetzt kommt
machen wir es kurz und fast sieben
jahrzehnte rät union in einem satz
zusammen der rote terror fünfjahres
klingel der humor der sieg über
nazi-deutschland der kalte krieg gegen
den kapitalismus und dann ein paar
ereignisse aus den 80er jahren diese
lieber vergessen würden afghanistan
tschernobyl wo der fall der berliner
mauer als symbol für einen endgültigen
zusammenbruch
[Applaus]
aus dem aus das war hat die udssr die
von den deutschen kaiser beamten guten
geister sind wieder geschichte die
büchse der pandora die sie öffneten
haben ronald reagan und michail
gorbatschow wieder geschlossen aus den
trümmern der udssr der union der
sozialistischen sowjetrepubliken sind 15
unabhängige staaten entstanden
15 republiken die von der sowjetischen
propaganda oft als die modernen family
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts präsentiert
wurden allerdings mit weniger komik und
mehr hammer und sichel
am ende würden diese republiken mehr
zank und anfeindungen untereinander
haben als die blutrünstigsten familien
clans in game of thrones und jetzt kommt
da noch putin daher der aus dass
führungsrolle im postsowjetischen raum
mit einer organisation rechtfertigt die
der europäischen union konkurrenz machen
soll und diese organisation hat einen
namen die eurasische wirtschafts uni
ohne
das erste was sie darüber wissen wie es
ist sicher wer alles zu dieser
organisation gehört sind dass alle
länder der ehemaligen sowjetunion nun
zum leidwesen putins nein aber er
erwartet auch nicht die
wiederherstellung der sowjetunion
die vollständige wiederherstellung des
sozialismus ist meiner meinung nach
höchst unwahrscheinlich das land ist
jetzt anders es wäre nur um den preis
sehr schwerer innerer konflikte möglich
brauchen wir die wirklich
die sowjetunion verschwand um
weihnachten 1991 herum aber alle wollen
wir eine kleine persönliche frage haben
sich mitglieder deiner familie nie ein
weihnachten gestritten natürlich haben
sie das
nun im falle des kremls ist das doch
ganz ehrlich familie ist nun mal immer
noch familie
russland hat daher nicht versuch
unternommen werden jede mütterchen
russland zu sein und lud die andere
ehemalige sowjet-republiken in seinen
neuen zusammenschluss ein die eurasische
wirtschafts und kasachstan weißrussland
christan und armenien aber was ist mit
den übrigen republik nun deren
schicksale nach der auflösung der udssr
könnten nicht unterschiedlicher sein
zunächst einmal hätten wir da alle in
lettland und estland diese drei
baltischen republiken sind wie ihre
verwandten die in ein reiches land
ausgewandert sind es dort so etwas
gebracht haben und die jetzt eigentlich
nichts mehr von ihrem früheren leben
wissen wollen
dann sind da noch die drei länder welche
die sogenannte operation der
europäischen union bilden die ukraine
georgien und moldawien drei länder die
freihandelsabkommen mit der eu haben und
davon träumen oder zumindest halten sie
eine gewisse zeit davon eines tages
vollmitglieder der eu zu werden
in diesem klub befindet sich auch
aserbaidschan einer der wichtigsten
energiepartner europas der sich in eine
art dauerkonflikt bzw krieg mit armeen
beendet das er wiederum teil von putins
eurasische union ist
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass diese vier länder
gerne dem beispiel der baltischen
republiken folgen würden aber die eu ist
das sehr sehr zurückhaltend
schließlich haben wir noch die
restlichen zentralasiatischen länder
trifft ministern ist das durchgeknallte
gahmig dieser familie und lebt praktisch
in völliger internationaler isolation
die letzten beiden usbekistan und
tadschikistan haben ein kleines problem
sie verstehen sich nicht wirklich jetzt
scheint also unwahrscheinlich dass die
eurasischen wirtschaftsunion nach der
vor der nachricht schicken noch für sich
gewinnen kann rosberg ist an soll
beobachter in der von russland geführten
eurasischen wirtschaftsunion werden der
springende punkt ist nun dass usbekistan
als beobachter also eine art partner
oder lang das mit dem bündnis zusammen
arbeiten will an der seite von 0 daniel
steht dass es leid ist ständig auf
brüssel zu warten deswegen orientiert
ist sich langsam wieder richtung moskau
um zu sehen was putin so alles auf den
tisch legt
doch an dieser stelle sich die frage
wofür genau steht die eurasische
wirtschaftsregion inwieweit hält
russland die fäden in der hand und was
noch wichtiger ist kann diese
gemeinschaft jemals etwas ähnliches
werden wie die europäische union heute
werden wir natürlich alle diese fragen
hier auf visual politik beantworten und
dazu werden der zuerst einen schnellen
blick auf die geschichte werfen
wachstum schmerzen
[Musik]
die eurasische wirtschafts uni oder eine
schwierige geburt hinter sich und die
geburtswehen sind noch nicht vorüber
denkt mal darüber nach wie oft hast du
schon gehört dass die achse paris berlin
der motor der europäischen union ist
genaugenommen liegt dort auch ihr
ursprung die europäische union entstand
aus dem bündnis zweier länder nämlich
deutschlands und frankreichs die
zusammenarbeiten um eine gemeinsame
zukunft aufzubauen nachdem sich ein
jahrhundert lang einen krieg nach dem
anderen geliefert hatten die
ausgangslage im postsowjetischen raum
ist jedoch ganz anders drei viertel des
gebietes der ehemaligen udssr bildet die
heutige russische föderation und
russland allein hat mehr einwohner als
die anderen 14 übrigen republiken
zusammengenommen es liegt auf der hand
dass jede organisation die daraus
entsteht nach moskaus pfeife tanzen
würde
[Musik]
und wie du dir vorstellen kannst macht
diese aussicht den ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken natürlich angst all
diese länder wollen ihre junge
souveränität nicht wieder auf den
traualter opfern wenn sie eine ehe
eingehen mit der herrschsüchtigen
matrone nämlich man natürlich mit den
liedern texten russland
aber diese angst hat auch viel mit den
wachstumsschmerzen diese organisation zu
tun was uns ins jahr 2004 zurück gehen
im jahr 2004 eröffnete die europäische
union ihre tore osteuropa eine
erweiterung die russlands geopolitische
position in zweierlei hinsicht
schlechter zunächst musste der creme den
beitritt des baltischen republiken der
ehemaligen mitglieds staaten der
sowjetunion zur europäischen union mit
erleben dann traten auf polen ungarn
tschechien oder die slowakei der
europäischen familie bei und nach ein
paar weiteren jahren auf bulgarien und
rumänien damit wechselten praktisch alle
länder die seiten die einst teil des
wahltags waren dem symbol der
regionalmacht der udssr über den
kommunistischen blog
[Musik]
das war der auslöser für die bemühungen
des kremls eine eigene organisation zu
gründen die den postsowjetischen raum
wieder aufbauen sollte
und was war die zweitwichtigste republik
der ehemaligen sowjetunion genau die
ukraine
ausgehend vom russischen ansatz wäre die
achse moskau ks also so etwas wie die
achse paris berlin gewesen was ihre
fähigkeit angeht den neuen blog zu
führen dies würde das gefühl verringern
dass moskau den rest buchstäblich
verschlingen will klingt vernünftig oder
moskau kiew an der spitze eines neuen
internationalen blogs
[Musik]
wenn es da nicht ein klitzekleines
problem gebe die ukraine wollte nie
etwas mit diesem projekt zu tun haben
und holz gut so denn dieses hin und her
zwischen den interessen der einen und
der anderen gruppe hat in der ukraine
nicht weniger als zwei revolutionen
ausgelöst die erste war die orangene
revolution
bei den ukrainischen
präsidentschaftswahlen 2004 trat er aus
den östlichen regionen der ukraine
stammende und eindeutig pro russische
ministerpräsident viktor janukowitsch
gegen den pro europäischen
gegenkandidaten viktor juschtschenko an
der für einen nato-beitritt der ukraine
war zunächst gewann janukowitsch aber
die opposition prangerte so folgt einen
wahlbetrug an löste damit die starken
proteste der bevölkerung aus die zu
orange revolution führten schließlich
ordnete die justiz die wiederholung der
wahlen an und juschtschenko setzte sich
durch
wir haben aber schon erwähnt das ist in
dieser region der welt fast so drunter
und drüber zugeht wie im game of thrones
die koalition die geschenke unterstützte
brach schnell zu sammeln und seine
regierung wurde zu einer ziemlichen
enttäuschung wohl die ukraine zu dieser
zeit der ost partnerschaft der
europäischen union beitrat aber davon
abgesehen ist praktisch nichts weiter
passiert und so hat janukowitsch wieder
die wahlen 2010 gewonnen
und das timing hätte perfekter nicht
sein können mit einer pro russischen
regierung in kiew bekannt der kreml dort
an den fäden zu ziehen um die annäherung
in der region zu fördern zuerst wurde
eine zollunion zwischen russland
kasachstan und weißrussland gegründet
eine union der die ukraine nach den
plänen des kremls bald beitreten würde
die dinge in der ukraine wurden dadurch
jedoch immer komplizierter so dass
präsident janukowitsch beschloss die
verhandlungen mit der europäischen union
über ein assoziierungs und
freihandelsabkommen abzubrechen und
damit den weg frei zu machen um dem von
russland angeführten blog beizutreten
damit lieferte er jedoch den brot
verdient ausbruch der euro weiter an
revolution
und du weißt wie diese ausgeht mit
janukowitsch flucht nach russland doch
dieses mal biete kreml nicht untätig
ich lege der föderal versammlung einen
antrag auf prüfung eines
verfassungsgesetzes über die schaffung
von zwei neuen konstituierenden
einheiten innerhalb der russischen
föderation vor die republik wo die stadt
sewastopol
[Applaus]
nun du weißt die die lage in der ost
ukraine ist dort gibt es separat ist
ische guerillas die von moskau
unterstützt werden
und ja das könnte dazu geführt haben
dass sich russlands beziehungen zur
europäischen union und zu den
vereinigten staaten verschlechtert haben
aber gleichzeitig sandte putin eine sehr
starke botschaft an die anderen
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken entweder ihr
seid auf meiner seite oder ihr wisst
jetzt was auch in eurem land mit
russisch sprechende minderheiten
passieren kann und
nur zwei monate später wurde der vertrag
zur gründung eurasischen etwas union
unterzeichnet sowas aber auch aber
wartet es wird noch besser
[Musik]
fünf länder fünf ziele
nach diesem sagen wir etwas gezogenen
statt der eurasischen wirtschaftsunion
ist ein weiteres hauptproblem der
organisation das fehlen eines
gemeinsamen ziels denn jedes der fünf
länder aus denen die union besteht hat
seine eigenen ziele und glaubt mir wenn
ich euch sage dass diese sehr sehr
unterschiedlich sind
[Musik]
bewusst als agenda ist die
offensichtlichste regionale
wirtschaftliche integration ist die
formel zur steigerung des wohlstands
geworden auf diese weise erhalten
russische unternehmen einen breiteren
und stabileren markt für ihre produkte
und wie wir bereits erwähnt haben ist
die führung einer solchen organisation
im postsowjetischen raum für den kreml
sehr nützlich und hilft ihnen bei seinem
ziel russland globale position zu
stärken die rückkehr wurden mütterchen
russland eben
nichts davon bedeutet eine
wiederbelebung der sowjetunion es wäre
naiv zu versuchen etwas wieder zu
beleben oder nachzuahmen was bereits der
geschichte angehört aber diese zeiten
erfordern eine enge integration auf der
grundlage neuer werte und einer neuen
politischen und wirtschaftlichen basis
beschlagen einen mächtigen supranational
verband vor dazu einen der pole in der
modernen welt werden oder als effiziente
brücke zwischen europa und den
dynamischen asiatisch pazifischen raum
dienen kann wladimir putin 2011
und nun ist in diesem politischen spiel
jene wichtige rolle die eine farbe
halten war an kasachstan gefallen
denn als die eurasischen
wirtschaftsunion 2015 ins leben gerufen
wurde hatte kasachstan einen guten grund
vorsichtig zu sein ein viertel der
kasachischen bevölkerung ist russischer
abstammung
und das bedeutet dass der vorwand in
putin für die annexion creme benutzt hat
du weißt schon diese kleinen grünen
männchen die die russischsprachige
minderheiten schützen wollten auch dort
gelten könnte
aber im gegensatz zur ukraine hatte
kasachstan auch zwei dem ärmel erstens
wussten sie dass russland dringend einen
regionalen blog antworten muss nachdem
es wegen der besetzung der krim
erhebliche sanktionen des westens
hinnehmen musste und zweitens dafür
kasachstan dank seiner geografischen
lage über alternativen china investiert
doch stark oder ist derzeit wichtigste
handelspartner während die krim also
einen wichtigen anreiz hat er sich mit
putin zu arrangieren war kasachstan
nicht in die enge getrieben genug um zu
allem ja zu sagen und das hat die ganze
geschichte verändert
was mich das erklären russlands
ursprünglichen absichten für den
postsowjetischen raum standen darin eine
umfassendere union zu schaffen die ein
einheitliches währungssystem sowie eine
militärische und politische integration
umfasst aber dieser plan an der
politischen union wurde von kasachstan
klar abgelehnt dass dem wirtschaftlichen
aspekt vorrang einräumen wollte aus
diesem grund blockierte es russlands
vorschläge die eurasischen
wirtschaftsunion mit kompetenzen in den
bereichen außenpolitische koordination
ganz verteidigung visapolitik
medizinische versorgung und bildung
auszustatten kasachstan wies auch den
anspruch russland zurück ein arabisches
parlament einzurichten und machte
deutlich dass es durch den beitritt zur
union kein bisschen von seiner
souveränität aufgeben würde es ist fünf
jahre her dass sie den tarif diese
position kasachstans gegenüber der union
festgelegt hat unser nachfolger
präsident ok es bekräftigt sie genauso
deutlich
diego ist ein wirtschaftliches projekt
ohne eine politische dimension sie ist
eine partnerschaft souveräner staaten
die sich darauf konzentriert das umfeld
für unternehmen und investitionen zu
verbessern und handelshemmnisse sowohl
innerhalb der mitgliedsländer als auch
mit den ausländischen partner zu
beseitigen kassel newmarket ok-präsident
kasachstan so aber auch weißrussland
kredit es dann und armee ihre eigenen
gründe für einen beitritt zur union denn
im gegensatz zu kasachstan sie nicht
reich an bodenschätzen so dass russlands
vielversprechend von öl und gas zu
vorzugspreisen locken konnte
mit anderen worten das angebot billiger
energie ressourcen man ein größerer
markt will verkauf ihrer maschinen bei
gleichzeitiger aufrechterhaltung der
russischen zusammenarbeit waren gute
gründe für den beitritt
[Applaus]
tatsächlich steht weißrussland seine
unabhängigkeit praktisch unter der
fuchtel moskaus es gibt sogar einen plan
zur integration beider länder aber das
wurde mir in einem anderen video der
isis dann wiederum dessen
wirtschaftsraum re export chinesischer
produkte abhängt hat den bereits von
anfang an erkannt dass die bereits zuvor
geschafft eine zollunion nicht ausreicht
um das potenzial des landes
auszuschöpfen
also trat es ohne große widerstände der
eurasischen union bei natürlich wusste
man im kreml wie man sie noch ein wenig
mehr überzeugen kann russland stellt 1,2
milliarden dollar für den beitritt
kirgisistans portfolio zur verfügung und
schließlich wollte armenien seine
position angesichts des konflikts mit
seinem nachbarn aserbaidschan stärken
beide länder sind russlands militär
partner und armenien versuchte das
gleichgewicht zu halten indem es seine
beziehungen zum kreml stärkte bis jetzt
hat das aber eigentlich nicht wirklich
funktioniert
jetzt weißt du wie die eurasische
wirtschafts und entstanden ist oder was
ihre fünf mitglieder dazu bewegt hat
eben beizutreten aber jetzt wo wir an
diesem punkt angekommen sind denken
viele von euch vielleicht ok mag das ist
jetzt fünf jahre her was genau hat die
awo denn in dieser zeit erreicht und
welche die zukunft erwartet sie nun das
werden der uns jetzt mal etwas genauer
ansehen
moskau ist noch weit von brüssel
entfernt
falls die eurasischen wirtschaftsunion
in bestimmten punkten der sowjetunion
nacheifern wollte hat sie dies in einem
bereits geschafft sie ist genauso
effizient
nach fünf jahren haben alle das gefühl
dass diese organisation weit davon
entfernt ist die an sie gestellten
erwartungen zu erfüllen warum nun vor
allem weil sie immer noch nichts anderes
ist als eine organisation die von
ländern gegründet wurde die bereits
zuvor miteinander handel getrieben haben
und was noch schlimmer ist mit
volkswirtschaften die auf vielen
produktions ebenen miteinander
konkurrieren außerdem bringt russlands
dominanz in dieser besonderen union ein
zusätzliches problem mit sich
wenn die russische wirtschaft liest
bekommt die eurasische union eine
schwere grippe und das bedeutet vor
allem eines alle ihre mitglieder sind im
schweinezyklus die extrem schwankenden
rohstoffpreise gefangen steigen sie geht
es ihnen allen gut fallen sie geraten
sie ins spuren
als die ursprüngliche zollunion 2011 ins
leben gerufen wurde wäre der wind zu
ihren gunsten und öl preis war hoch die
russische und kasachische wirtschaft
wuchsen und auch weißrussland
profitierte davon doch als die
eurasischen wirtschaftsunion 2015 ihre
arbeit aufnahm befand sich russland nach
dem verfall des ölpreises und aufgrund
der westlichen sanktionen nach der
annexion der krim bereits in einer krise
in einer krise von der es sich bis heute
nicht erholt hat
seitdem ist die russische wirtschaft
immer noch nicht richtig in schwung
gekommen es war steigen die
rohstoffpreise nun wieder aber der
nächste einbruch ist so sicher wie das
amen in der kirche
[Musik]
russland kann diesen trotz des kreis nur
entkommen wenn es seine wirtschaft
stärker diversifiziert das problem dabei
seinen eigenen markt mit den produkten
seiner partner aus der eurasischen
wirtschaftsunion zu füllen ist dabei
nicht gerade hilfreich und das hat
starke auswirkungen auf die anderen
mitglieder denn der handel mit russland
macht nicht weniger als 96 prozent des
gesamten handels innerhalb der
europäischen union aus im grunde handelt
es sich gar nicht so sehr um eine union
zwischen staaten sondern um eine union
zwischen ländern die extrem vom handel
mit russland abhängig sind wie du am
beispiel weißrussland sehen kannst macht
der handel mit russland fast die hälfte
des gesamten außenhandels des landes aus
für den rest der mitglieder ist die
situation nicht viel anders im gegensatz
zu diesen mitgliedern dann macht der
gegenseite gern will für russland jedoch
kaum acht prozent seines handels
portfolios aus mit anderen worten aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht ist dieses
bündnis für moskau gar nicht so wichtig
wie zunächst angenommen außerdem ist die
idee eines gemeinsamen marktes noch
lange nicht verwirklicht
es gibt immer noch viel protektionismus
geschützte sektoren die nicht teil der
wirtschaftsunion sind und setzt in den
sektoren in denen es eigentlich keine
schranken geben sollte behindern die
länder häufig den handel und ihre
nationalen produzenten zu schützen und
führen dabei alle möglichen
administrativen und technischen gründe
an wie zum beispiel gesundheits und
veterinär kontrollen
so echt zum vertrauen und freihandel
nach dem vorbild europäischen union ist
ist noch ein langer weg denn wenn es
wirklich darauf ankommt gehen die dinge
nur sehr langsam voran zum beispiel
sollte bis 2019 ein gemeinsamer
strommarkt geschaffen werden in der eu
eine selbstverständlichkeit dieses
vorhaben musste diego jedoch bis
mindestens 2025 aufschieben zu groß
waren die hürden
die schaffung eines einheitlichen öl und
erdgas marktes für 2021 geplant wurde
aber quasi in letzter minute verschoben
auf unbestimmt und der hauptgrund dafür
ist dass russland gar nicht so sehr
daran interessiert ist aber warum
eigentlich nun weil die energiepolitik
ein wesentlicher bestandteil der
russischen außenpolitik ist ja genau der
außenpolitik energie ist für den kreml
eine wichtige waffe mit der es viele
verschiedene politische ziele
durchsetzen will aber das ist für
regelmäßige zuschauer von visual politik
nichts neues russland macht sowohl
geschäfte als auch politik mit seiner
natürlichen ressourcen und zwar
gegenüber der eu wie auch gegenüber
seinen partnern in der eu
die armenische regierung zum beispiel
gehört nicht zu den allergrößten fans
und deswegen hatte in gaspreis letztes
jahr als überall die preise sanken
einfach mal um zehn prozent erhöht
aber ein moment denn auch seine freundin
manipulierter kreml herrschaften will
ihre energie abhängigkeit so setzt
russland sein erdöl ein um weißrussland
unter druck zu setzen die logik dahinter
minsk soll ja nicht auf dumme gedanken
kommen und weiterhin in die union
zwischen den beiden ländern investieren
aber fairerweise muss man sagen das ist
nicht nur schlechte nachrichten gibt
denn die eurasische union hat auch
einige positive ergebnisse vorzuweisen
die arbeitnehmer freizügigkeit hat zum
beispiel die situation in armenien und
kirgisistan entspannt da ihre
arbeitslosen bürgern leichter zugang zu
arbeitsmöglichkeiten und einem neuen
leben in russland haben diese
flexibilisierung war für alle von
vorteil einerseits bekommt russland das
ist eine schnell altern der bevölkerung
hat dringend benötigte arbeitskräfte
andererseits schicken migranten aus
armenien und kirgisistan jedes jahr
milliarden von dollar aus russland nach
hause auf der positiven seite steht auf
die unterzeichnung gemeinschaftlicher
freihandelsabkommen mit anderen ländern
so können die kleinen mitglieder der
union von der verhandlungsmacht moskaus
profitieren es wurden erfolgreiche
abkommen mit zu unterschiedlichen
ländern wie ägypten zerbian vietnam und
singapur geschlossen außerdem hat die
eurasischen wirtschaftsunion ein handels
kooperationsabkommen china unterzeichnet
und das ist nicht die einzige regionale
macht mit der sie ihre beziehungen
gestärkt haben iranischer
regierungsbeamter eu freihandelsabkommen
101 zwei bis drei jahren in kraft treten
natürlich könnte diese offene
handelspolitik der rettungsanker für
diese organisation seien die bisher vor
allem vergleich zu anderen staaten
bünden sie nicht unbedeutend war
tja und an diesem punkt angekommen
schließt sich die frage welche zukunft
siehst du für die eurasische
wirtschaftsjunioren kann sie sich als
union konsolidieren und die
wirtschaftliche und sogar politische
integration ihrer mitgliedsstaaten
stärken wird sie ein instrument des
fortschritts sein oder wird sie
lediglich russlands macht und einfluss
in der region zementieren wie immer sind
wir auf eure meinungen zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat falls ja
gibt es mit einem like teil ist mit
euren freunden und vergisst nicht das
abo mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen was gut und bis
bald
[Musik]